how's it goin breaths many spirit
welcome to some more outlast I didn't
expect that but there's a new DLC it's
called whistleblower I don't see a
reason of me babbling about I think we
should just start playing it Jesus
normal hard nightmare insane
let's try nightmare hi since we play the
first game
I'm boughs that's right man I'm so
excited for this I actually I really
like the first game as a whole I know
some people in like the story or blah
blah blah but I thought I really liked
it I'm down for the mall I'm more than
happy for somehow that is I'm on the
flower
hey man thanks appreciate it
so Who am I what are you doing don't
stop it oh [ __ ] guys we don't have to
wake up but open your eyes
out of that work yeah you did
don't make out with me bleep oh god he's
making out with man oh oh that's you
getting these alerts real trouble at the
engine house I hope me stop it
[ __ ] [ __ ] come on
filming it hey your porn gonna be famous
finally it's a Lowell pain but it's
gonna be worth it two hours earlier I
was hoping for a split second that we
would continuous the guy who died in the
first game birkoff's psychiatry you
don't know me let's make this quick they
might be managing I did two weeks off
with cousin burka then they [ __ ] those
guys terrible things happening there
don't understand it so this is a pretty
cool
I didn't do any research it sure seems
like it what is he writing
people are being hurt and Merkel is
making money it needs to be exposed it
is a secure email I'll just break the
name concorda all right
that's pretty cool I had no idea hey
there's page three three times already
there's something urgent in the engine
all right engine what are you doing in
here anyway
what oh just a software guy ah oh we're
here
what the fudge cake what aren't you
answering my page I'll tell them you
incoming I was not looking at porn at
least hi sir step aside please
did it twists no all right well [ __ ] it
I'll go in here then what are they all
doing playing candy crush a man I
haven't seen [ __ ] in years Waylon hurry
up they're waiting on you oh god damn it
don't tam it nice hat bro all right here
we go
why aren't you working
why don't you doing lazy ass I got to do
everything here well this mark guy in
here move [ __ ] he's got 15 seconds to
keep it job
ah here we go park finally from you been
functional imaging interfaces and
talking to the ASL we got a patient 30
seconds out and we're blind inside his
head I call it a chamber ask them to
delay know what I would know need
another before its evaluation mister
partner is gonna have us up and running
before we even know it oh [ __ ] to the
park uh yeah
dad is not deleting all your [ __ ] I'm
back
are we happy mr. Park yes yes yes very
happy thank you
so happy it worked so happy everything
is fine as the Waylon Park which I
consider more than I'm kind to his
programming skill and considerable
dedication to the merkon corporation
[ __ ] me they're bringing in uh-oh oh
that's the guy that we kill happy happy
happy
right what
oh hi
Hey calm yourself this is a
high-security all right agent I'm sure
he's still common are you gonna finish i
never seen nipples that big before that
was horrible
quickly ahead pork head need to roll it
happy happy
not active when we put them in the end
happy 5 seconds ahead 3 oh god what the
filing is back I know this is a hentai
Jesus positioning imaging place
seriously you're finished oh Jesus wait
don't expect anything but honestly my
review of your performance be wet if I
wanna see moan okay I'm doing it's a
custom around here you're done here mr.
Park thank you and goodbye
you're welcome [ __ ] Matt is on the floor
what so from the other in China in your
hole all right going Jesus calm your
tits I need to exit the room sir go in
you're not getting one but nice hat
still sir great hat wonderful hat what a
[ __ ] idiot
fake-ass [ __ ] all right let's go great
I'm out of here
great great day guys okay sing yeah all
right going for a little stroll out um I
guess we know we're not going in there
we're are going off [ __ ] sake haha okay
whoa what the file
Kandra I could steal I know I'm sorry I
consulting contract 82 software engineer
with a level three security clearance
graduated [ __ ] laude from Berkeley but
still somehow not smart enough to
realize that the last thing to fly on
the Doudna spider's web now I think that
a borrowed laptop onion router and
firewall patch would be enough to fool
the world's leading supplier of violence
Wow
I'm sorry that was crazy
I'm afraid we're gonna have to have you
committed mr. Parker you willingly
submit to forced confinement
much did you hear that agent no he said
yes no I said okay I said yeah I'm just
here mr. Waylon Park volunteer for the
morphogenic engine yet yes iron brave
the Murkoff corporation in the onward
march of science both appreciate your
bravery maybe you could administer the
car here a light anesthetic oh thank you
from the behind please
ah come on Jesus can you blow my whistle
I won't happen ever again that's pretty
I forget a beginning it seems it's weird
cuz this so far the story seems a lot
more interesting than the first one well
that's awesome
that explains it huh
oh yeah this is listing room we were in
I think we've seen all of these oh [ __ ]
so we're playing as one of the patients
how get oh damn free camera mine [ __ ]
Yoink
now now why in the hell would I pick
this at oh oh that's nice that's great
okay I remember the controls
okay Pitts you got this no problem open
please why don't you open oh hey
beautiful oh alright hang just please
open the door
oh he's gonna open the door I think I
think oh it's open
thanks brah high five cool
alright let's get the [ __ ] out of here
oh [ __ ] Oh God god I don't like this
like this close the door I need to take
a [ __ ] it's been all day
there we go crash stupid I'm sorry okay
just don't kill me
oh that's nice
all right nice
oh hi oh [ __ ] oh god I don't like this
Oh job done what a fake it if Ruger no
not here oh come on wait what what oh
can you blow my whistle baby
I need soda yeah [ __ ] a little soda
where the [ __ ] am I um batteries with
the mollyconor gecko huh ready hey don't
do that Prez all right guys whatever the
[ __ ] kind of [ __ ] up hey can I come
in here hey please
these after I came from behind that's
not fair what the [ __ ]
think I'm think I gotta go this way Oh
gly [ __ ] dick in the face why do I
say [ __ ] like that I'm alive
oh god I'm alive what the [ __ ] it
oh god what that watch hello what the
[ __ ] are you looking at
[ __ ] you look like a frag is it safe
hi hi
oh great drew best room wow so good
[ __ ] Let Me In okay we'll go here oh
that's pretty cool
hi guys great party great fun haha can I
make out with him now alright
if you should be bottled up - uh okay -
cool oh no no no I'll do it
no problem no no what no but I wanted to
stab him great ass
it's to make a great corner
oh sorry I didn't know you were looking
all right they're saying all right
can the temptation all right he doesn't
change his mind
all right I'm going Oh could you move
away sir all right well I better get
some good material hmm I'll call you mr.
bunny baby
how do i oh this is the way
ha ha ha ha ha silly me not a silly
silly gooses later hey rude boots up
blood what the [ __ ] in a duck's face no
Carla you didn't twister [ __ ] mother
[ __ ] passes Mickey
[ __ ] why would the [ __ ] name
thank you
I hate every no why do you doubt it
dummy I don't like it my salad app all
right first I gotta have to enter that
episode a it's really awesome so I think
this is gonna be a great series of this
DLC so if you leave a like I would
really much appreciate it it helps me
out a lot and it makes me love you in a
bit more
that's impossible all right stay awesome
bros love you Baja